how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel cinematic
universe and over the weekend there was
a
crazy report that came out stating that
jennifer
lawrence has been cast for the mcu's
sue storm aka the invisible woman
of the fantastic four a huge report if
true and we're gonna dive into it and
thank you to skillshare for sponsoring
this video more in them in a bit now a
few months ago at disney's investor day
kevin feige did talk about the fantastic
four he said the movie is
in development and they're working on a
feature right now
but this report not only says that
jennifer lawrence has been cast
as sue storm but she is actually on her
way to australia to film a scene
and this does seem a little bit early to
be shooting for the fantastic four but
according to a different report
the scene that she is shooting is
actually not for the fantastic
four it's for a different mcu film now
there's a lot being discussed about
these reports online with all the
insider trades and i'm gonna break down
each report and everything you need to
know so let's start with the first one
but first if you love marvel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu videos
now we know that thor love and thunder
is filming in australia and according to
a report
from the daily telegraph marvel studios
is also planning on using this set in
australia to film the fantastic
four not only that but the daily
telegraph also reported that jennifer
lawrence
is already on her way there to film it
the website daily mail also stated that
jennifer lawrence is involved in a
marvel project
and a couple of days ago
geekocitymag.com also reported that
jennifer lawrence was being eyed
for an mcu role now jennifer lawrence is
a
huge actress a very high profile actress
so she's not just going to play
any role in a film she's not going to
play a minor role in a marvel studios
film so of course what everybody is
saying and what has been coming out over
the weekend
is that she is going to be playing sue
storm the invisible woman which of
course makes perfect sense
and she does kind of fit the description
pretty well for a sue
storm now of course it does seem like it
would be a little bit early to start
filming for a fantastic four
film especially if you consider the fact
that kevin feige the president of marvel
studios during the investor day
said that john watts the director of the
spider-man homecoming films is also
going to be directing the fantastic four
films and right now he's in the middle
of shooting spider-man homecoming 3.
so the fact that they're saying jennifer
is involved with the fantastic four and
is going to film right now
seems a little bit premature and in fact
justin krull from deadline tweeted this
morning stating
all i'm gonna say is this marvel just
started meeting with writers on
fantastic four there's no script and it
will be a while before the film starts
shooting
now interestingly enough he did not
comment on the jennifer lawrence report
he commented on the filming which means
that jennifer lawrence still could very
well have been cast
as the invisible woman and according to
geekgossitymag.com jennifer lawrence
could be going to australia right now to
possibly shoot a post-credits scene
for thor 11 thunder which is shooting
there currently now since the marvel
writers
are meeting right now that means they
are considering or have
already considered who exactly they want
to play the fantastic four members
what kevin feige the president of marvel
studios tends to do
is meet with actors and actresses years
and years in advance before
finally arriving at a role that would be
really perfect for an
actor they did this with jake gyllenhaal
they met with him about plenty of marvel
films before deciding that mysterio was
the perfect character for him
and not too long ago he admitted that he
meets with keanu reeves about every
single marvel film they make
to see if there's a character that would
work unfortunately there has not been a
character that would work for keanu
reeves in the marvel cinematic universe
yet but it is safe to assume that marvel
studios
if they wanted jennifer lawrence has
been meeting with her for some time now
and of course she does have major
connections to marvel as she played
mystique
in the fox x-men series which is another
thing that if this report is true makes
you wonder about this decision
for her to play the invisible woman
she's already played mystique in another
marvel universe and spoiler warning
upcoming for
one division click away now if you're
trying to avoid any they already brought
evan peters's quicksilver back
and fans are very confused right now now
granted they have a master plan and it's
all going to be revealed in the next
couple of episodes but it doesn't really
seem like marvel is that worried
about the confusion aspect as long as
you have a good story and can play it
off properly or have a good character in
mind for that actor
now another thing i'll talk about is
emily blunt and john krasinski but first
thank you to skillshare for sponsoring
this video
and again thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for
creative and curious people over the
last year i've used skillshare myself
watching videos on youtube watching
videos about photoshop and other film
editing software programs and i've used
it personally as well such as watching
videos on how to play the guitar and how
to get better
if you are looking for a place to
explore your creativity or to simply get
better at things
such as youtube or editing or playing an
instrument skillshare is the perfect
place to learn all of these things
and the great news is is that the first
thousand of my subscribers to click on
the link in my description will get a
free trial of skillshare premium so you
can explore your creativity
and if you're not one of the first
thousands don't worry it's only ten
dollars a month with an annual
subscription so it's very very
affordable if you're interested in
youtube classes you can check out the
teacher sorel
amore just click the link in the
description down below to get started
now a lot of the fandom right now really
wants emily blunt and john krasinski to
play sue storm and reed richards they
both
absolutely look the part and reed and
sue are married in the comics and
jon and emily are married in real life
and we know that marvel studios has
indeed met with both emily blunt and
john krasinski but perhaps this
is another jake gyllenhaal thing perhaps
they meet with them about a lot of
different marvel studios projects until
they find that perfect
role for them now again justin crowe
from deadline said that the script isn't
even written yet but he didn't mention
anything about jennifer lawrence so take
this report with a grain of salt and may
be true it may not be true but either
way
let me know in the comments down below
if you would like it to be true
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos and i'll
update you if we hear any more about
this report don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me